what's up elimination it's Evan I need
your help and answering these two
special questions please leave your
answers if you've enjoyed the content on
my channel and you want it to get better
and you want to be more customized for
you these two questions will help me
make better content for you so the first
question is what time are you consuming
my content are you consuming it in the
morning do you watch and spresso in the
morning do you watch the top tens at
night I'm curious when mostly are you
consuming the content I'm releasing
videos at usually 8 a.m. Eastern noon
Eastern and then 8 p.m. Eastern I mean
7:00 a.m. Eastern like 7:00 a.m. Eastern
noon and 8:00 p.m. Eastern and I want to
know if that's gonna be the best
schedule to keep on going forward if
you're watching it stressful in the
morning and you're following that
routine I love it if nobody's doing it
then maybe I'll switch it up and do
something else so I'm really curious
what time of day are you mostly
consuming the content on my channel if
you're coming back multiple times per
day
that's awesome leave that down there
below it'll really really really help me
the second question is where are you
when you're consuming the content what
are you doing so are you in the car or
you're driving somewhere do you have it
over breakfast you have it with your
coffee in the morning do you have it
over lunch to have it after dinner where
are you I'm curious where you physically
are what you're physically doing while
you're watching my videos you know are
you working then you have it on the
background are you working out and you
have it you know in front of you where
are you what are you doing so those two
questions be really really really
helpful to me for those of you who've
been loyal viewers and leave the
comments all the time I want to see you
guys down there
and for those of you who've only watched
who've never left a comment ever who
maybe watch it on TV please go to the
computer for the first time leave a
comment on my channel because I really
need your feedback to make this channel
even better going forward as I planned
into the next coming ones and next year
as well what time of day are you
consuming most of my content Russian 1 &
2 where are you
what are you physically doing while
you're consuming the content that would
be really really helpful for me thank
you guys so much for all the support
we're about to cross 1 million hopefully
next month I really appreciate it none
of this happens without you guys and a
lot of the content that I make is based
off your feedback and so I'm asking
again for your feedback today the hell
like the channel even better thank you
guys so much I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much loved
guys I'll see you soon
1 1 Sigma 1 this volume you have the
most important word ever
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
Apple so it would be like a little
beacon hey believe nation if you want to
know what the most important one word is
for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details